Alright, so let's take a look at this monster of a function. Once again we
start by defining whether or not this is a static or dynamic object, and of
course setting the proper flag to the body definition type. So the first thing
we do is we actually start off by defining whether or not this is a static or
dynamic body and assign a particular flag to the type property of the body
definition. Next, since the calling function probably has information about
where they want this object to be spawned, we go ahead and set the position x
and position y value so that the physics object can actually exist in the world
in correct place. From there we call registry body function which will of
course invoke box 2D to create a physics object and return to us a handler
representation of it and then we go through with creating a fixture definition.
Now, the defaults for a fixture definition object are generally pretty good and
that's what we use for most objects and grids. However, for the bouncy fixture
we actually changed the density, friction and restitution, so that when an
object hits a wall, it'll contain a lot of its velocity moving away. This means
that bouncy bullets maintain a high velocity and ability to kill other players
since they don't lose any energy in impacts with walls. Finally, what we'll do
is actually create a shape object with a new polygon shape as standard API
calling defines, and then we'll call SetAsBox passing in half width and half
height. From there we call the CreateFixture objects which attaches this
definition to the body object and return it out to the calling class. And if
you got all that, then you deserve a cookie.